foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right good morning everybody you
don't get a sip because that's not
really my thing I leave that to Stephen
when he is sitting in this chair but I
still have the mug and it's still got a
wonderful tasty warm beverage in it uh
glad you could be with us today it's a
little bit of a different day
um we don't always get the time to fully
dive into certain topics and so we'll
we'll take an entire hour to do that on
occasion you've seen us do that before
when we did the investigative piece on
McKenzie we did it when we die we kind
of dove into the career of Muhammad Ali
A lot of different times we we take a
chance and uh go into a subject that we
think that you are going to be
interested in and and this one this is
not much of a chance you need to be
interested in this
um today's subject it really does fit
perfectly in the realm of something that
requires us to dive just a little bit
deeper and I appreciate you guys giving
us your time before we jump into it
really quickly I just want to make sure
that if you are not a member of mug Club
you go to ladder with crowder.com mug
Club to sign up 89 you get this show you
get the Hodge twin show you get Alex
Jones you get the Mr guns in gear you
get Brian Callan you get Nick depalo
ladies and gentlemen all of the guys I
mean every single one of these guys is
fantastic it affords us opportunities to
do shows like this as well where it's
not just kind of the the normal show
that we do which is fun and exciting and
there's always great topics to discuss
there uh but every once in a while we
need to take a minute and dive just a
little bit more deeply into a subject
and really let me just kind of start at
the beginning and then I'll introduce
Our Guest who is waiting very patiently
for that moment I appreciate that I was
watching a movie called the creepy line
and I believe it was around when it came
out 2018 was when it came out I either
watched it then or I watched it in 2019
and this was a basically a movie or kind
of a documentary about how Google would
manipulate its search function and
particularly you know potentially end up
leading to manipulating elections there
were a lot of really creepy things not
to steal the name of the movie
but it just really it bothered me and it
was something that I didn't know much
about so do me a favor comment below did
you know anything about the movie the
creepy line the documentary or maybe
some of the work related to how Google
could be shifting elections manipulating
you into voting uh if you're in the the
right district and happen to be of the
right political party persuasion and
that party needs to turn out the vote to
win that District were you aware of that
I think you will be after today and
unfortunately
it's going to scare the hell out of you
but that's okay we've got somebody on
the case for us today and joining us
today in third chair is Dr Robert
Epstein
[Music]
psychologists are now for publicizing
the influence of search engines and
you've kind of had this this very
storied career and this has been
something that has kind of flipped the
script on you a little bit right you're
not a conservative let's start out there
it's okay though we're all going to be
okay right we're all going to talk and
have a discussion where we have things
that we definitely agree upon but maybe
some of the other issues we don't
approve that's okay with everybody
you're not a conservative but
conservatives kind of drug you into this
a little bit and your world kind of
turned up something tell me a little bit
about that in 2016 when that happened
like what what was Google doing and how
did you get connected to Donald Trump
and the Trump family and being a
conservative and no longer a scientist
let me just point out that you you have
a gun on your desk I do yes so I'm not
going to point it at anyone though don't
worry it's safe inanimate objects rarely
kill anyone it's usually people that do
the doing and none of the people here
want that to happen so okay because I'm
next time I'm coming with protection
myself don't worry I'm packing next time
it's totally acceptable here in the
studio there are a lot of firearms
around for everybody's protection not
we've never used them on each other no
ever no not once that we can remember so
tell me what happened that kind of that
kind of threw things I'm imagining that
kind of turned life upside down just a
little bit
um well it started turning upside down
actually on uh New Year's Day in 2012.
because I got a bunch of messages from
Google
there might have been eight of them or
even more saying your website has been
hacked and we're blocking access
so you know I've been a programmer my
whole life or at least since I was 13.
and I was interested I mean you know
everyone's websites get hacked it's very
common Google itself has been hacked for
sure but why was I getting messages from
Google why not from a government agency
or some non-profit organization who made
them the sheriff of the internet so that
was the first thing second I noticed
that they were somehow blocking access
not just on their search engine which
makes sense it's theirs but they were
blocking access on Firefox which is
owned by a non-profit organization
they're blocking access on Safari which
is owned by Apple how could Google
possibly do that I did eventually figure
that out and I published a big
investigative piece in U.S news and
World Report people can get to it at
thenewcensorship.com and I explained
about Google's black listing they have I
I go into detail about their black
listing that was published I think in
2016 I had never seen any of these
blacklists that the none had leaked yet
uh since then they have leaked I was
writing about things which I knew
existed within the company because I'm a
I'm a programmer uh and I wasn't
guessing I knew for sure that these
things existed but the point is I I was
learning
a lot about them and getting more
concerned about them 2012
2013 I started doing experiments because
I started to think wait a minute Google
maybe has some power here that we're not
aware of right there there were
marketing studies for late 2012 that
caught my eye because the marketers were
pointing out that if you could just move
up one notch in those search results
that could increase your sales by 30
percent it could make the difference
between life and death for your company
if and if you get knocked off that first
page oh yeah you're dead yeah you don't
exist because when was the last time
that you went down to the little Google
thing that had the numbers and how many
pages and results came up and clicked
next oh it was exactly never ago so
exactly remember you barely scrolled
down past the bottom of the current
screen I don't I don't know any time
that I actually get all the way down to
that part of the page anymore so you're
right life is found in that top half of
that first page well actually fifty
percent of all clicks go to the top two
I item so I was thinking if people trust
those high-ranking items if they trust
those high-ranking items so much could
those high ranking items be used to
shift people's thinking maybe their
opinions maybe their purchases may be
their votes
so I'm a researcher this is what I do so
I did a controlled experiment early 2013
I predicted that if we randomly assign
people to this group or that group
candidate a or candidate B and in
candidate a people see search results
that favor candidate a so if you click
up high you you get to a web page that
makes that candidate look really good if
you're in the other group it's the
opposite So Random assignment good
scientific methodology and I thought
with this kind of manipulation I could
shift voter voting preferences by two or
three percent the first shift we got was
something like 43 which I really yes of
course which I I did not believe
so we had so we were like okay run that
again exactly so we and we're not doing
this with college sophomores by the way
we're doing this with the full full age
range people who look like the American
voting population we do it again we get
66 percent I I I'm thinking wait a
minute you know we triple check we we
did it over and over again
the the bottom line is is that I ended
up discovering something called which is
now called seam s-a-m-e the search
engine manipulation effect if you go to
search engine manipulationeffect.com
you'll actually see the the seminal
publication which was in the proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences
which is kind of a big deal if you're in
science yeah it is absolutely in any of
the sciences and that you know that that
described five experiments in two
countries more than four thousand
participants and it described one of the
most powerful manipulation techniques
that's ever been discovered in the
behavioral sciences in a hundred years
seem
and basically it means wait a minute
Google has this power
and it's and it's not like
the power to put a TV commercial on the
air or to buy Facebook ads this is a
very different kind of power because
they have a monopoly on search Worldwide
yeah what is it 85 of the search Market
is controlled by Google that's more than
92 percent is it really worldwide and
it's going it's going up still
and so Bing and DuckDuckGo haven't
really dented well Bing is about two
percent Doug was about one percent they
don't they don't impact elections yeah
but if you have that kind of control and
you can shift opinions by that much
without people knowing because people
don't even know
I mean how would you how would you look
at a bunch of search results and
recognize that they're biased toward one
candidate you'd have to click on
everyone look at the web pages read the
web pages you know so people don't know
and you can't counteract what they're
doing so it's unlike Billboards and TV
commercials and radio commercials
because if you buy a billboard I can buy
two Billboards exactly well and a lot of
people when you go and search you're
just assuming that an algorithm is
basically taking whatever keywords that
you're putting in and finding you the
Articles or the the sites that are most
relevant minus some paid spots right we
know that they're sponsored posts and
stuff like that are sponsored listings
or or you know maybe like the first four
but they always note those as being
sponsored or paid or an advertisement
right and you're just assuming okay
whatever I get next has got to be the
most relevant thing to what I've typed
but you're saying it's not or
theoretically it's not
I'm saying that they they
fool us because most of the Searchers
people conduct about 86 percent are for
very simple facts what is the capital of
Texas is is it really that necessary are
people really that afraid of just just
factual statements getting out or at
least opinions that are said his
opinions well well some information
uh there there are forces out there that
they that they don't they don't want
that information out there so they they
suppress it and it turns out that uh
obviously the the the press in general
has always had that ability for sure but
the Press is very competitive so you
know it's hard to you want the story
nobody else is covering right right if
everybody's running this direction and
somebody comes to you and says well wait
a minute no I've got this piece right
here you're going to run with it because
it gets people to buy your paper click
on your website Whatever It Is Well in
general too we have a relatively Free
Press but probably the freest of any
country in the world so you're you know
there are different points of view are
are out there the problem though with
content on a platform like Google
is that there is no competitor and
there's that trust that we have not just
in Google but in algorithms and computer
output we have this trust I mean we've
been studying this now for more than 11
years we've been measuring it people
really trust that they trust those
high-ranking search results for example
they trust the search suggestions
Google's flashing at you search
suggestions believe me that's part of
the game here they manipulate us from
the very first character we type into
the search bar literally I mean if you
don't believe me pick up your phone or
your computer type the letter A they're
going to flash some suggestions at you
and chances are that some of them or
most of them are going to be for Amazon
now you're you're looking for aardvarks
you're looking for apples you're not
interested in Amazon some other a do us
a favor so that's a really great thing
let's do this everybody out there right
now do this go to Google type in the
letter A I want everybody to do the
exact same thing just the letter A not
capitalized and then take a screenshot
of what you get I want to see how
different those results are across this
audience and send it to us at any of our
social media accounts you can make sure
you put up we'll put it up on the screen
here for you to see where to send it to
at s Crowder on on X I always want to
call it Twitter still because that name
is just that there's so much kind of
brand identity behind that sure and
Equity built up but put it out there I
want to see it and I want you more
importantly to be able to see what
everybody else's results are and how
different they are now that's that is I
mean if it's Amazon then they're pushing
a company right but it seems innocuous
enough where you're like okay it could
be different after we finish our
conversation you'd be like holy crap
okay now I see it I've done an
experiment and you've shown me this is
weird so so keep going I didn't
interrupt there but when I when I was
testifying before Congress and if you
want to see my testimony just go to
Epstein testimony.com as you can see
I've bought a lot of you I was about to
say you own a lot of websites yeah
whoever you're hosting through really
likes you
so when I was testifying before Congress
Epstein testimony.com uh
I I I I gave this challenge to Senator
Ted Cruz and he pulls out his phone
right in the hearing and he types in an
A and I said well okay tell me what you
see three out of the four suggestions
were for Amazon really yeah and he said
well why I said well because Amazon is
Google's biggest Advertiser and Google
is Amazon's biggest single source of
traffic these are business partners
we've shown in experiments that just by
manipulating those search suggestions
they're flashing at you we can turn a 50
50 split among undecided voters into a
90-10 split with no one yep with no one
having the slightest idea that that has
occurred but so give me give me a little
bit more information there so so what
what would happen so if I was on Google
right now and I was typing in some
information are are you saying like
something like how do I vote or which
candidate or what did Trump say or what
did Biden say like what am I typing in
that is skewing me or is all of the
above well first of all if you type in
something that has a bias like you type
in Hillary is is the devil then of
course you're going to get
related search suggestions but if you
just type something simple like Donald
Trump is you should get a get a mix of
things probably uh Hillary Trump is you
should get a mix of things well 2016
before that election uh on Bing or Yahoo
if you typed in Hillary Clinton is you
got what people were generally searching
for which ironically you could verify at
the time on on Google Trends which was
things like Hillary is the devil Hillary
is sick Hillary eats babies whatever all
those crazy things babies but if you
typed I mean I'm not a fan of Hillary
Clinton but I wouldn't say that she's a
baby eater no I don't know where that
one came from
but the if you type that in though on
Google that summer of 2016 or you got
nothing like that you got Hillary
Clinton is winning and Hillary Clinton
is awesome which no one was searching
for so what we learned in our research
is this is what Google does when they're
supporting a candidate or a Cause
they suppress the negative search
suggestions ah so you're only getting
neutral or positive which is going to
take you usually which is going to
generate if you click on it it's going
to generate search results that are kind
of neutral or positive right and you're
rarely if ever going to see anything
negative because they're suppressing the
negative search suggestions so that can
take that 50 50 split and turn it into a
9010 among undecided voters among
undecided people are undecided on
anything it turns out Google has that
ability to manipulate with search
suggestions answer boxes which give you
the answer the search results Google
owns YouTube they're manipulating people
with a sequence of videos with the up
next video they are also it turns out
indoctrinating our kids which is a new
area of study but for us but the point
is that if you had the slightest idea of
what Google is doing
for example they monitor
all your gmails
not just the ones you write not just the
incoming emails coming from whatever
they're coming from
of the attachments uh how about this
your start you're typing an email
because you're really mad at your
girlfriend your boyfriend your boss and
you're typing this horrible email and
what you're saying and then you look at
it and you go wait I'm not sending that
that's crazy and then you erase it
Google already has recorded it yeah
that's part of your your profile now
when you if if you people knew the
extent of the surveillance and the
extent of the manipulation first of all
I guarantee you they would stop using
Gmail I guarantee you they would stop
using Chrome which is a Google browser
they would stop using Android phones
because that's okay yeah you know what
now we're on the same page there we go
I'm not saying I'm a Tim Cook you know
loyalist or anything I just like the
products a little bit better than
Android but continue you're singing my
tune
I'm just saying that there's a there's a
there's a world of hurt here that people
are just unaware of and that is the more
I have studied it the more I've learned
about it the more concerned I've become
first of all because I'm a dad so I'm
concerned about young people and what
are they seeing and you know is there is
there any hidden messaging going on
there is anyone trying to shift their
thinking in any particular way
well one of the leaks from Google uh
which is I think in 2018 or so 2019 was
an eight minute video from their
Advanced products division which is
called the selfish Ledger
not their Advanced products division but
this video videos called the self
selfish Ledger and if you type in the
selfish Ledger plus my name you'll get a
transcript of it and you'll get a link
where you actually can go see this video
this video is about the ability that
Google has to re-engineer humanity and
they they say in the video they call it
receive resequencing human behavior
according to it's right in the film
company values really
yeah so whatever they deem to be the
correct Behavior it's sounding like the
Chinese Communist party without actually
having the communism or the party it's
just this big Corporation that's doing
this that's that well it's terrifying
it's actually without anything worse
it's much worse because without any
accountability to anyone and they're
controlling all of this stuff the
surveillance the censorship the
manipulation in every country in the
world outside of mainland China
uh and they're accountable to no one so
it's much much worse than China I mean
ever the Chinese know they're being
surveilled and manipulated by the
Chinese government the Chinese
government doesn't hide that but here
you've got a private company that's
accountable to nobody we didn't elect
them again who made them sheriff and who
gave them all this power and why why
aren't our public officials doing
anything about this that's the question
that I think a lot of our audience will
have because look we we've discussed
this before you're very familiar with
the hunter Biden laptop story and how
that swayed the election so I think it
was a combined total of 17 percent would
either have switched their Vote or
simply not voted for Biden just just the
suppression of that one story uh
potentially could change an election
suppressing somebody's voice on YouTube
so like you said owned by Google could
change the outcome of an election could
change the pushback on restrictive
policies regarding lockdowns or masks or
things that you disagree with or could
hide things maybe that you do agree with
right so it can censor people and their
arbitrary rules we've had strikes on our
channel for things that that don't even
make any sense and there's no there's no
way for us to to get around it there's
no way for us to to appeal it and get
them to change their minds on something
that doesn't work they say there's an
appeals process you can submit click
here if you disagree with this strike
and it's like yes it basically goes to
the trash bin I think somewhere at
Google and notifies them that aha maybe
we need another strike to uh to get back
in line with uh with YouTube the problem
is that politicians aren't doing
anything and we've had Senator Ted Cruz
on we've had Senator Marco Rubio on
we've had a lot of people on and I'm
like look guys enough talking about
section 230 as it specifically relates
to those platforms right enough talking
about it either you do something about
it or you don't exist
and I'm not saying that's us I'm saying
that's them if you don't do something
about it and they are exactly who you
say they are and they are skewed against
conservative
policy makers then they could just make
it to where people don't find you and an
election comes around and you should win
but you don't and you've lost your
opportunity to do anything and I think
probably on Section 230 you would agree
like hey this is part of the the problem
I saw you nodding your head when I
mentioned it like section 230 kind of
being this ambiguous thing where they
get the benefits of not being sued but
none of the responsibility to allow
voices on as long as they're not
breaking the law right and we have rules
and guidelines for that what that looks
like otherwise it should be you have the
ability to have some free speech in the
Public Square but they're not even
allowing you to do that that's the
obvious stuff we know about that that's
become like a car alarm to us
unfortunately we get a strike on YouTube
and it's like yeah it's a Tuesday fine
that happens this is even worse and so
let me let me just kind of rewind a
little bit to 2016. so
where did you get your PhD
a conservative Bastion uh a little a
little University in Cambridge
Massachusetts it's called Harvard
Harvard okay so Harvard train you're a
smart guy right you're you're not a
conservative so that would make you or
would you call yourself a liberal
Eileen left lean left okay perfect leans
left supported Hillary Clinton and then
this happens Donald Trump tweets out wow
report just out Google manipulated 2.6
million to 16 million votes for Hillary
Clinton in 2016 election this this and I
think this next book this was put out by
a Clinton supporter not a trump
supporter Google should be sued my
victory was even bigger than thought at
Judicial Watch
some context there those numbers aren't
quite right I believe I think you said
potentially up to 2 million to 16
million or 12 million whatever it was I
think he was off a little bit on the top
number and it didn't go into some of the
Nuance but immediately what happened
Hillary Clinton replied to him now she
had no reason to reply to him at all
none and what she said was this she said
that that research has been debunked
which is it completely Vols uh but I
checked with lawyers that's that's an
opinion so you can't really and she said
and it's based on data obtained from 21
undecided voters and I went what and
where did she even get those ideas from
I'm sure that someone at Google gave her
that language that then got picked up by
this machine which I had heard of and I
didn't know it was real but it got
picked up by the New York Times and a
hundred I did a fact check I read it
today 100 other mainstream uh news
sources many of which I've dealt with in
the past I know the people I've
published in them before and I got cut
off I was just like dershowitz I got
completely cut off from mainstream media
mainstream news uh even though again in
many cases I know the people I mean I
was editor-in-chief of psychology Today
magazine for four years I for I mean I
worked for New York magazines yeah and
uh they cut me off
how did that so as somebody who leans
left how did that make you feel I mean
because in your mind you're like guys
I'm going where the data is telling me
like we have a massive problem here that
you should care about too and that's
really all you're saying just because
Donald Trump chose to grab a hold of
that in that moment shouldn't have
shouldn't have changed what what was
going on but it seems like it did what
oh it it's uh in many ways let me
explain
that
Trump's tweet came in the summer of
2019.
that was and it was shortly after I had
testified before Congress right about my
work
and that's also that summer I gave a a
private briefing to a bunch of State
Attorneys General
uh including the guy who just got off
the hook in Paxton Ken Paxton who who uh
who actually is had been really really
aggressive and getting more and more
aggressive against Google over the years
and so
I'm standing out in the hall there's all
this all this the summer 2019 one of the
AGS comes out and he says well based on
you know what you told us Dr Epson he
said I don't want to scare you but he
said I think you're probably going to be
killed in some sort of accident in the
next few months
and then he walks away I know exactly
who it was he's still in AJ and I
obviously I'm here so I wasn't killed
right but my wife was right and that was
a very sad story that you and I were
talking about but it's not just a sad
story it's terrible I'm married I have
two young kids how many kids do you have
five you have five children what are the
what's the oldest and youngest give me
the spread here oh I don't want to oh
okay they're older are they older are
they young it's a spread okay it's a
spread all right so I have two very
young children right now and so I'm just
entering into the dadhood phase and
that's that's a terrible thing and that
would be enough
but there's more to that story
that makes what he said to you one of
the Attorney General Attorneys General
there said to you
kind of ring kind of in the back of your
mind a little bit like wait a minute can
I trust that this was just an accident
so just just give us a couple of things
there because when I read about it I was
like you got to be kidding me well the
little pickup truck and that she was
driving
um I mean some things were just they
were not right the the truck was never
examined forensically it disappeared
from the impound yard I said where where
is it and they said oh it was the
remains of the truck were purchased by
some dealer in Mexico so it had
disappeared to Mexico that's your
property though right but I thought it
was my property
that doesn't make any sense did they
ever give you an explanation for why no
no and an explanation at that point
would wouldn't have made any difference
because the thing was gone
so uh you know and I did talk with a
woman who was actually in the car right
behind her and from what she the way she
was explaining it to me it sounded like
something had gone suddenly wrong with
her breaks and of course brakes can be
tampered with but yeah anyway who knows
the problem is I'll never know no I know
and I'm sorry for that and that I don't
want to I don't want to relive it for I
don't want you to dive deeply into that
but
you're now in a position where
you're you're you aren't suicidal
correct I just want to make sure I get
that on the record right now if we end
up finding you did not kill yourself
right that's and we joke around about
that but at the same time it's it's a
real thing because these are very
powerful forces that probably don't want
you tinkering with what they're doing
well I have to keep going on X formally
Twitter yeah and I had to do it again a
few days ago and I have to say just a
reminder everyone I am not suicidal now
why do I have to keep doing that because
just a few days ago there was a very
good article came out about my work and
about what I'm doing now to try to stop
these companies which I'm sure you'll
want to talk about sure and uh it was in
it was in a a publication called PJ
media which I think is very good
although it leans heavily to the right
but still I think it's very good and uh
anyways this article about my work in PJ
media and it said and it Compares me to
another Epstein he was in Epstein and it
says you know they do have one thing in
common because this app Stein that I'm
writing about now me
is just as likely to be suicided as the
other Epstein was yeah so I go so I have
to go back online and say I'm not
suicidal but I I am doing work which is
definitely
uh inherently dangerous because
my team and I and I have almost 50
people working with Me Brave Souls um
yeah and you know we are we're
discovering things about Google and to
to some extent some other tech companies
that are really scary because for one
thing we've learned how to not just how
to test the powers that they have that
we do in our basic science our basic
experimental research and that's good
enough to know but then okay now what do
I do right exactly so you know that's
part of it the basic science that that
tells about their capabilities which is
interesting but that doesn't mean
they're actually doing anything right
right but we've starting in 2016 we have
learned how to preserve what at Google
they call ephemeral experiences now in a
million years they never imagined that
anyone was going to capture the
ephemeral content that they show people
so what's ephemeral content why is that
so I'm glad you asked the question
because it made me seem smarter for not
having to maybe the audience would like
to know I know but maybe they don't know
but I'll just tell you and then pass it
on
so ephemeral means fleeting short-lived
and by definition ephemeral means it
disappears and you can't go back and see
what it was right 2018 there's a leak of
emails to the Wall Street Journal of
course and of course and
what are these what are these googlers
they call themselves what are they
discussing how can we use ephemeral
experiences to change people's views
about Trump's travel ban well wow my
head spun when I saw that because I had
been studying in experiments since 2013
of the power that ephemeral experiences
like search results or ephemeral search
suggestions are ephemeral answer boxes
YouTube sequences up next videos that's
all ephemeral and here were employees of
the company saying basically
acknowledging that they know the power
that these ephemeral experiences have to
shift people's thinking and Behavior now
that's incredibly dangerous that they
know this and presumably maybe even do
it I'll get to that in a minute
because
it disappears in other words it leaves
no paper trail normally when people
commit a crime there's a paper trail
right exactly it's very hard to
prosecute and you know if if you believe
that the election was stolen by you know
these machines doing stuff or voter
fraud we were talking about that before
how do you prove that it's one of the
hardest things this is worse this is
worse because these things don't leave a
trace it makes it even harder and so for
you to have come up with a way to
monitor that and to catalog that massive
amounts of data I'm assuming that is not
cheap by the way right to be able to
store that to process that to pay people
to do it like how how I don't know if I
want to go into the details of how but
you guys have a system let's just say
that what's the name of this system that
captures all this data in there like a
network name or something for it that
you guys have internally we call it our
monitoring system but publicly now we're
starting to call it America's digital
shield and we actually have a mock-up of
a website that's going to be up soon
it's going to be live that is going to I
hope generate a lot of interest
uh yeah there we go we've got it right
there all right and
well we have learned to do better and
better and better starting in 2016 is to
preserve ephemeral content so how do you
do this well
imbeciles at places like The Economist
and Columbia University and I have to
call them imbeciles because is this a
Harvard snob thing a little
competitiveness a little bit maybe a
little bit that's okay that's nice
University but you know what they did to
try to see if if there's bias in Google
content they'll use it and they use an
anonymized computer and that one
computer over and over again they're
running searches and then they look at
the stuff and they say there's no bias
there's no bias there's no bias okay you
can't look at anonymized
at content coming from an anonymized
computer because their algorithm
recognizes that as a bot it recognizes
that it's not a real person yeah because
it doesn't have a long 20-year history
of data in there in you know in their
database so they can play it all square
because it's a bot potentially and not
show bias oh we've shown this yeah we've
shown this if if they know that's not a
person they just send perfectly unbiased
stuff really so how are you gonna see
the real stuff so now we starting in
2016 we've come up with better and
better ways of recruiting people around
the country we call them our field
agents they're all registered voters
they're real people and we hide their
identities just like the Nielsen company
hides the identities of the Nielsen
families that they use to get the TV
ratings same thing it's very very
expensive very slow very labor intensive
but each day we have a team of almost 50
people who work on this each day we're
able to successfully recruit
vet
NDA
equip train uh every day another 30 to
60 people and then we've started getting
some of their kids signed up too
so we
in 2016 we we miraculously got 95 field
agents in 24 States preserve 13 000
searches on Google Bing and Yahoo
looked at the actual search results the
real people were getting and found there
was extreme bias in favor of Hillary
Clinton whom I supported and I no longer
do obviously but the point is that uh we
calculated from our our research at the
time that that level of bias if it had
been present Nationwide would have
shifted between 2.6 and 10.2 million
votes to Hillary Clinton with no one
knowing as it happened she won the
popular vote by 2.8 million votes so it
looks like if you took Google out of
that election the popular vote would
probably have been very very close very
close
we built bigger system in 2018 2020 we
didn't have 95 field agents and 2020 we
had 1
735 field agents in four swing States
because that's where the action is and
we preserved more than 1.5 million
ephemeral experiences
and we found guess what extreme
political bias favoring Joe Biden who am
I supported but I no longer do
anyway uh there so wait a minute that's
that means that they shifted more than
six million votes to Joe Biden wait a
minute yeah shifted six million more
than six million at least six minutes
can you tell me what the swing states
were
uh if I can remember I think Florida
Arizona Ohio
fourth one and I don't know could be
Michigan not sure okay so these are
these are states that change an election
potentially right because I know that we
know that there were razor thin margins
in these places now so what was it in uh
in in Georgia it was 11
000 votes or something like that uh in
Arizona and in Michigan and Wisconsin it
was really really really close
Pennsylvania was close all these places
2020 Georgia was one of the forests so
I've left out Georgia but Georgia we had
more than Georgia was okay we had more
than a thousand field agents just in
Georgia because there was so much going
on there there were those two six
million in just those four
yeah but it gets the story gets really
crazy now because we at this time we we
were learning how to analyze data faster
and faster and faster so uh
I sent it to Senator Cruz's office why
did you pick Senator Ted Cruz because
after I had testified a few months later
he invited me to DC we had a four-hour
private dinner talking tech for four
hours that's why the man is really smart
these issues he is yeah so I I sent him
the data that we had
a couple days later November 5th so this
is two days after the presidential
election Crews and two other Senators
sent a very threatening letter to the
CEO of Google if you want to see it go
to letter to
googleceo.com
and you actually see the letter written
by these senators and now the Shocker
November 5th 2020
Google that day shut off all of the bias
going to voters in Georgia how do we
know because we had more than a thousand
field agents there why does this matter
because they were at this point gearing
up for the two Senate runoff elections
in January but Google backed away from
that election literally the bias wish
we'd never seen this happen before the
bias in Google went to zero Google
search went to zero but more important
those their partisan go vote reminders
that they had been sending out
stopped so tell me what the go vote
reminder is is that on the search page
where are you talking about that oh no
no this is far more dangerous this is on
this is on Google's home page which is
usually blank but now and then they put
a big message there it says go vote that
says go vote or register to vote or mail
in your ballot they they can put
anything they want there but what we
have found is they do this in a partisan
fashion so for example one example 2022
in Florida a hundred percent of liberals
got that go vote reminder all day on
Election Day uh that go vote reminder I
mean that Google's home page has seen
500 million times a day just in the
United States
but a hundred percent of liberals got
that reminder in Florida 2022 only 59 of
conservatives did really that is a
really extreme manipulation because we
know from actual research that Facebook
conducted and published that in that
kind of election a national election if
Google is sending out a go vote reminder
in a partisan way
then literally on Election Day itself
they can send 450
000 more votes to one candidate than to
the other they can get people to vote
who would normally stay seated sitting
on their sofas all day they can get that
many people off their sofas the point is
they stopped
they they stopped so this this
illustrates a very important point that
Justice Brandeis made over a hundred
years ago which is sunlight is the best
disinfectant and this second part of
that quote which no one knows except me
is and Street lamps are the best
policemen yeah
that's what Justice brand I said
1917 or something like that it's perfect
and we use it all the time and we don't
use the full one we're going to change
that
you can't just use sunlight as the best
disinfectant anymore you have to have
the cops thing in there that's right by
the way are you are you starting to get
the picture a little bit here is this
not a little bit creepy and scary like
got a couple of guys in here doing the
doing the stuff the tech wise that is
like
these guys are like
really
are you serious a little shot so let's
let's just I just want to back this off
just a little bit and make sure that you
guys understand
this shifts
so many elections potentially
and nobody should have that power no
matter what my particular belief
would be about candidates or who should
be in office or it should be a vote not
somebody remind I mean they have get out
the vote campaigns we know that it works
because candidates have been doing it
for as long as voting has been a thing
right where you go through districts
that maybe you need to win this one a
little bit but make sure you do a get
out the vote campaign have door knockers
have people calling have people giving
rides have signs out to remind people to
go vote because they can't be bothered
in their daily life to remember that
it's an election day that's kind of an
important thing to determine who is
going to be in charge of your area or
your country
and they do this to swing in just one
state you're saying 400 and some odd
thousand no no Nationwide Nationwide to
go 400 000 votes to one candidate one
candidate just on Election Day alone
with that manipulation the the hardest
question go vote manipulation now uh
there's also a bit of good news though
because the fact that we did get them to
back off the fact that's right so you've
got some results that's right so what
this was telling us was wait monitoring
could be the solution here to a lot of
the terrible things that they are doing
and again we have more and more evidence
over time
2022 we had
2742 field agents all registered voters
by the way they are these field agents
are politically balanced there's no bias
and and we're very careful to
politically balance them so because we
publish our work in peer-reviewed
journals so we're following all the
rules to make sure we have credible data
so at this point we're in 10 swing
States
uh give you a couple of little glimpses
of what we found uh first of all they
shifted Google easily shifted tens of
millions of votes in hundreds of
Elections Nationwide they all shifted in
One Direction uh I happen to like the
direction but I don't like the fact that
a private company is running our country
that that the free and fair election is
an illusion I don't like that at all so
why are and and I I understand that and
we're not making this about your
political beliefs we've already said
we've kind of stated where we are and we
have a very solid footing Uncommon
Ground here but I have to ask you this
question like why
why are all the Liberals out there
saying the freest and most Fair
elections that we've ever seen one
that's a stupid comment because how do
you prove it's the freest and most Fair
election that we've had in our history
as a country I didn't realize that the
other ones were less free and fair
before that and I'm not talking about
the 2020 issues but then why is one side
out there saying hey
no these aren't necessarily we need to
make sure that these elections now it's
not just a bias of our guy didn't win
right it was I'm seeing some stuff and
this doesn't look like it's fair but
then the other side completely saying
well no these are the freest and fairest
elections that we've ever had why is
that okay my answer is going to surprise
you okay but it's actually the truth you
think it's just candidate bias my guy
once I'm happy with it or no no okay no
I'm gonna tell you the truth and all I
can ask you to do since it's going to
sound a little nutty okay yes
that's okay did I mention that Alex
Jones comes on this show oh my God so
I'm saying we're fine we're in good
company Alex is if you've ever met Alex
he's one of the nicest guys you'll ever
meet it's it's hilarious you wouldn't
you may think he's like this intense guy
that kind of runs around these by the
way he's been right so many weird times
where I'm like that's crazy and then six
months later I'm like well son of a gun
he said they returned to the Frog's gay
and it sounded weird but there's this
there's the report
well you know he just invited me to be
on his show I I don't know what to do I
have my limits he's a great he's
honestly great guy I've spent some time
with him I've gone down to Austin I've
done a show with them like he's he's
been up here a lot he's he really is a
great guy he's very fair he'll ask you
some questions for sure but uh but yeah
so tell me I'm putting my tinfoil hat on
tell me you're you're where it gets
creepier I'm gonna tell you something
else again it's you'll have to mull it
over okay but it's the it's the actual
truth okay and if if you want to read my
written version of this
uh you do and it's it's how Google
stopped the redwave.com you're saying
they mess with 22.
oh yes big time okay all right but here
I'm gonna shut up here it is here it is
you know this uh Fascination almost an
obsession that some conservatives have
with things like ballad harvesting and
messing with voting machines and ballot
stuffing and on and on and on all that
stuff yeah
all of which by the way was claimed by
you know Google's League excuse me
Trump's legal teams in 2020 and that got
thrown out of 63 courts all that all
those beliefs all that stuff is actually
spread by Google and to a lesser extent
some other tech companies now why would
Google want to spread a bunch of
conspiracy theories and get people
believing that stuff and get people
repeating that stuff and then and then
Inspire uh oan and Newsmax and fox to
run story after story after Story why
would Google want that
because they do what magicians do yeah
they use misdirection they want you
looking over there because they don't
want you looking at them yeah and that
is the truth so these stories most of
them are completely false even the ones
that are true they don't have much of a
net impact on elections so even you know
attorney general Bill Barr tried to
explain that to Donald Trump made no
difference the point is they don't have
much net impact because they're
inherently competitive yeah inherently
competitive I just saw a speech by
Senator Steve daines
uh when she's complaining about all the
ballot harvesting that the Dems did in
2020 he said we got to get better at
that
I mean that's the point you see what I'm
saying these are inherently competitive
techniques they have relatively little
net effect but Google which wants you to
believe in all these conspiracy theories
what Google does is different because
they're not shifting a few hundred votes
here and there a few thousand votes here
and there they are shifting millions of
votes in ways you can't see and you
cannot counteract
that is that is insane I I'm gonna tell
you this when you started talking about
that I kind of figured that you were
once you started talking about it I
figured where you were going to go with
this and the reason that I can say that
guys you can go back and you can look at
our shows when we had uh mayor Giuliani
on and said why are we going after these
and just to be clear on the 63 cases the
vast vast vast majority of those are
either thrown out for standing or
procedural issues that never actually
even got to Discovery where the judge
basically said nope we can't go down
this road not going to go down this road
it wasn't that the entire thing was
adjudicated and determined to be false
but your point I think is very valid
because it was my point as well
regardless I was saying why are you
going after these things like the main
point that you can go after now in your
case you're saying hey guys we need to
be focusing on Google I agree 100 but we
also need to be focusing on States like
Pennsylvania that change their
constitution illegally they went to the
Supreme Court of Pennsylvania who did it
and said well yeah that's fine I know
it's supposed to be in two legislative
sessions back to back the point is there
were much more solid grounds to go on
and to try to make arguments now see
you're you're actually proving my point
you're that was right though we
researched that they just didn't bring
that case you're you're still you're
you're and you're proving my point
because as as Mark Twain said it's easy
to fool people but hard to convince them
that they've been fooled and you are
proving my point and I have a feeling if
you and I chatted and chatted and
chatted more and more and more you would
you would come up with stuff that you
think is real and big and consequential
and you know what it's probably not
because dirty tricks have always been
played they always will be played for
sure they're inherently competitive what
you have to do is you have to look and
say wait where did these stories come
from how are they circulated remember
this these tech companies have 100 power
to control
virality
no it's not
99.2 it's 100 they decide what stories
go viral and what stories do not if
stories like that
about Pennsylvania or any other state
and and some dirty tricks and uh I know
Dominion voting machines I don't lump
those two things together I know I know
what you're saying but Pennsylvania is
is something that you can look in the
court documents there and see what
happens Divinity voting machines saying
the ghost of Hugo Hugo Chavez
manipulated the votes in there that's
crazy right I I I'm just telling you
that you have to
what I have been studying for a long
time now is a whole different kind of
Beast and the Beast oh your Beast is way
worse it's way worse because it's the
one we have to be fighting I'm agreeing
with you 100 I'm just making the point
that there were even though he didn't
know you're gonna do it again you're
gonna do it again let me say it this way
even though Giuliani didn't know about
the Google thing or if he did he wasn't
doing anything about it
there were stronger things to go after
and fight against
than what they did go after and what it
did is played perfectly into the hands
of Google by Google's own manipulation
most likely is what the case you're
making people would believe in the
conspiracy theories what I'm saying is
the Pennsylvania case is not a
conspiracy theory ah stop stop hold on
how do you how do you say it is
I literally looked into the sessions let
me tell you the law in Pennsylvania you
cannot have mail-in voting unless the
legislature meets in two separate
sessions and approved it they met in one
and they didn't meet in a second now you
could make the argument yes but that
didn't sway the election and I would
grant you that premise okay maybe it
didn't but it was something that
happened that I'm like why did they do
that covid you're still doing it why do
you think seriously I'm gonna I'm gonna
take that gun okay no I'm genuinely
trying to understand like I'm not
pushing that as like the grounds for the
2020 election or all I think if if we
were prior to the Google story it'd be
Hunter Biden's laptop thing right that
that's much more consequential you know
across the country but in this
particular case why is it not okay for
me to be frustrated that states did
stuff like that or at least in this one
case it happened all right so I could be
uh I'm not saying that overturns
everything I'm just saying that
frustrates me it's like well but you
have laws and you broke them in this
case and that our main point was mail-in
ballots is a hard thing to do
doesn't mean it's going to help me
doesn't mean it's going to help this guy
it's just a hard thing to do I I can't
it's going to take a bigger gun than
that apparently to have any effect here
I'm trying to tell you this that I have
given speeches to Big crowds of tea
party people all of whom were carrying
guns I have I've given none of them use
them on you see we're nice well I've
been soda sewn up nicely let's say but
the point is that uh uh I've I have
scared people I've gotten them for a few
seconds to kind of consider the truth of
what I'm saying and then they go right
back and they're they're if they're not
talking about
Pennsylvania they're talking about well
yeah but what about this thing in Ohio
but what about this thing I I have
friends in Arizona now who just keep
going on and on and on about voting
machine stuff in in Arizona and you know
I just testified before the Arizona
State Legislature
you know what now and then someone
actually gets it because Carrie Lake who
lost the governorship lost that race in
she has now gotten it she gets it and
she's actually saying now wait a minute
maybe she was distracted with some of
these small issues and maybe really
maybe she should be looking at the tech
companies and guess who else gets it
ramaswani ramaswani is now saying well
all those things you're concerned about
yes they're all real we should be
concerned but there's the thing you
didn't give me the butt though you told
me that that was silly and I'm saying
well hold on now I I agree that your
thing is bigger and it's the thing to
focus on because you can't really do
anything about these other things even
if they are real and they're much
smaller in scope right yeah see but it's
not a little bigger no I didn't say it
it's a lot bigger it's like a little
it's the game it's like a tiny little
marble compared to like the sun it's
it's a whole different kettle of fish
it's really really scary because it's
operating on a massive scale by 2015
Google was deciding the outcome of 25
percent of the national elections in the
world
and that number has gone up over the
years
can I talk about monitoring systems can
I talk about the digital Shield because
this is I I don't have much Faith yes
Cruz is very impressive I admit but I
don't actually have much faith in the
legal system especially these days or in
regulators
uh because in general law and regulation
even without massive dysfunction yeah um
laws and regulations move very slowly
Tech moves yeah speed of light kind of
by definition you're actually going to
one of my next questions but my I guess
my to sum all of that up was we need to
be focusing on this
all this other stuff is the distraction
I'm agreeing with you and we need to be
doing that so how do we do that because
I I don't we run up against problems all
the time that we find and that frustrate
us and we don't necessarily know how to
have an effect to change things right so
you have a monitoring system out there
how do we practically go I want to back
that guy
and jump in with you on this
and then for you said this you're the
guy standing between us and
this stuff kind of falling apart and
that's a that's a strange thing but
somebody said that to you it was in an
article right a random Divine the woman
who broke the story for the New York
Post on Hunter Biden's laptop if you go
to Epstein in the newyorkpost.com you
will get to her recent piece about my
work and she ends that article it's an
amazing article I could not have paid
someone to write a better article she
ends it with only Epstein is standing in
the way
no I I I did not pay her to do that I
mean she said well I'm sure you you
probably never set out to have that
sentence exist with your a minute I
don't know who would
I I I don't think I've ever blushed
before reading an article but I I think
I probably did blush reading that I mean
wow
now why would she say that what what is
it that I'm doing well in 2022 we didn't
have
95 field agents we had
2742 field agents in 10 states we
preserve more than 2.5 million ephemeral
experiences on multiple platforms and we
got faster and faster and faster and
faster at doing what we're doing and I
made a decision which is kind of risky
and in fact this is where your people
and
did we come to the did we come to your
Aid the Crowder people this is where
your people uh
could be very helpful because I made a
decision very risky I decided okay the
time has come
we have to go beyond elections this
country needs a permanent a permanent
monitoring system monitoring the tech
companies 24 hours a day in all 50
states we need to have representative
samples it needs to be politically
balanced so all our data are Court
admissible
and we will either catch them and put
these people in jail or we will stop
them and when we stop them we'll see it
in the data because we'll see the bias
disappear we will see the crazy stuff
that they're sending to kids will stop
we will see the go vote reminders those
partisan go vote reminders they will
stop we'll see it yeah and in a way that
would be the best thing for our
democracy and for our Republic that
would be the best thing is that we just
stop them they just stop and by the way
if I were them I would stop because
so we started building last fall I
managed to get just over three million
dollars from some some very generous
donors who believed in in this
monitoring concept uh where we now call
it America's digital shield and we
started building and as of today
let's see I knew I knew this was going
to come up so I went online you have the
website I need to know what uh website
search engine he uses I'll get to that
okay
as of today at this moment we have 11
638 field agents all registered voters
in all 50 states plus 2 377 children
and we have preserved more than 41
million ephemeral experiences on Google
on Facebook on YouTube on Bing Yahoo and
other Platforms in other words we're
building it yeah now our goal is to try
to have a full system in place with
representative samples Court admissible
by the end of this year so we can we can
actually go right after the primaries
literally we can protect the primaries
uh and you know we're we're on the way
but the three million
is pretty much gone okay and and I'm in
a very tough position right now because
to shut this system down would be insane
it would be even more insane than the
fact that I built it but it would be
insane to shut it down because that
would be literally handing over
the free and fair election to the tech
companies permanently probably and
handing over the minds of our kids to
the tech companies permanently
but I don't know I I'm not a fundraiser
I'm a very good researcher
so the money I'm kind of baffled there
uh you know and I need I need help right
well how can we help what do you want to
what do you want people watching this
show right now and look I do you spend
your hard-earned dollar as you will
right we encourage you to join Mud Club
that's one of the things that you can do
to help fight back against stuff like
this but what do we do in practice
because we always talk to you guys about
making a difference practically it's not
just about hearing about a story that
gets you all rah-rah fired up it isn't
about that it's not we're not looking to
just do this to get people to watch our
show and just to be entertained we try
to do entertainment as well as news and
kind of make it somewhat palatable and
help preserve you know the the ability
to have free and fair elections that
that's first and foremost so here's an
opportunity here's an opportunity to
kind of put your money where your mouth
is and and I'm assuming that you guys
take donations big and small doesn't
matter right you'll you'll whatever
people can do to kind of support your
cause where do they go if they want to
pitch in
the you should go to my
googleresearch.com but okay let me let
me just point out that when I go on a
show
that has a big audience which this show
does and I go on a show I get a
gazillion people trying to reach me or
reaching me saying I'll be a field agent
I'll be a field agent so don't do that
don't do that because right we can't
ever accept volunteers because if we
accepted volunteers Google would send us
thousands of volunteers and we know
because they have sent us people they
will water it down of course so that
they can control the system yeah so we
have to we have to find people using the
methods that we use we find registered
voters uh so don't do that well we need
are funds now we only pay our field
agents 25 a month it's just a token fee
for the privilege of being able to look
over their shoulders when they're you
know getting content from these tech
companies we preserve and protect their
privacy so when that data is transmitted
to us it has no identifying information
ever and we only look at data in
aggregate so we're doing exactly the
opposite of what the tech companies do
the tech companies look at your
individual data and then like the misers
they are they you know they they they go
oh look more data and then they monetize
it and they use it to manipulate you
we're doing exactly the opposite so we
preserve people's privacy
but we only pay them 25 a month but if
you we have 11
000 already yeah that and that number is
going to be much much higher that's a
lot of money if you want to help us
sponsor a field agent I mean literally
go to my Google research my Google leave
that up at the bottom right Michael just
put that up at the bottom and leave that
for a little bit mygoogle research.com
if you guys want to do it so you can is
it set up like you can just pick to
sponsor or are you just saying give 25 a
month as the the dollar amount is it set
up that way instead of you can just
click monthly and put any amount you
want if you want to sponsor five field
days or ten field agents we've had we're
getting right this minute uh and and and
this is wonderful
we're we're getting about a thousand
dollars in small donations every single
day from people we don't know
and you know again that's that's been
that's amazing that's wonderful but do
you know what it costs us that's not
enough to run this I'll say it for you
it's not enough
it's fantastic it's wonderful but we can
do better if we want to preserve free
and fair elections this is a very very
big project because it has tremendous
people needs
there's a it's a
it has a tremendous security needs which
are very very unusual because we have to
protect the data and we have to protect
our people it's a very expensive project
which at the moment is costing us more
than ten thousand dollars a day to build
and that's gets us 30 to 60 New Field
agents every day who've gone through the
whole process
and it's expensive so if anyone out
there if you have connections to a major
Foundation connections to a generous
person who can afford you know a major
gift
uh I I can't do this myself I I
literally need help from other people
but the good news is we've gone a very
long way in a relatively short time and
we started building this permanent
system uh last fall we now have 11
638 field agents all registered voters
in all 50 states
as far as those representative samples
go we've hit that minimum in 10 states
so far so we're going state by state by
state are you starting kind of in swing
states where your focus is because like
you said that's where the action is
going to be we did start with the swing
States because those are absolutely
critical in elections but we're after
far more now because the content we're
seeing because we're getting data now
from kids yeah and it's not from kids
it's from the their devices right we're
seeing the content that's being sent to
their devices they don't even have to be
in front of their devices we're still
seeing the content and that is actually
getting me even more concerned than the
political bias because these companies
are sending
data to our kids that is so creepy that
at the moment we don't even know how to
analyze it I'm done I'm telling you the
truth yeah YouTube videos that kids
actually watch because what the data
we're getting shows the kids are
actually watching these videos
it'll be like a something that kind of
looks like it's just a crappy cartoon a
parent walks by just sees a crappy
cartoon keeps walking
four or five minutes into the cartoon
boom someone's head explodes something
horrible happens it's very brief
speaking of ephemeral it's very brief
but then if you look on on YouTube you
can do this if you go down along the
bottom uh yeah you can see what parts
people watch the most exactly right and
there'll be a spike right at that point
where this terrible thing happens
because kids Replay that over and over
again now why would they do that because
that's how you addict people to content
or to your platform that's how you
addict them because we are drawn all of
us to accidents on the side of the road
of course yeah you can't take your eyes
off certain kind of negative content
bias wow I know a few things I mean wow
that's a first no seriously not for me
human in general it wasn't directed at
me no I'm a Notre Dame man come on wow
I'm very impressed that is called
negativity bias for those in the know in
the social sciences it's been studied in
many fields it's very very real and very
powerful
uh you know that's what Google makes use
of when they suppress negative search
suggestions because if they let negative
search suggestions appear those negative
Search terms will draw 10 to 15 times as
many clicks as neutral or positive terms
it's the same kind of deal
anyway Google is making use of
negativity bias in content that they're
sending to our kids that's insane to
addict kids to that platform and to
increase watch time which is the number
one metric they have for Revenue right
uh so let me just clarify in that
cartoon scenario that you have one I'm
assuming that people would want to be
able to kind of verify something like
that are you guys able to capture that
kind of data because you were talking
about not really even knowing how to
capture that yet are you able to capture
that where you can actually see it
happen again and show somebody see this
is what I was talking about
is provable or at least admissible
Replay that tape because uh uh I think
you may have missed a couple words that
we know how to capture it we're
capturing from kids now we're capturing
massive amounts of data 24 hours a day
we know how to capture it we don't yet
know how to analyze analyze it okay so
because how do you we can watch the
video we can see the creepiness in the
video but by the way by the way though
there's a creepiness that goes beyond
even that you know that one horrible
moment right
the traumatic moment there's there's
creepiness all through that where we
know is important but we just don't know
yet how to articulate the importance of
it and we don't know how to analyze it
uh mathematically yet but we will figure
it out in a scalable way obviously right
that would that I mean this we're
talking about massive amounts of people
that would be needed just to watch this
stuff and then to extrapolate like you
said mathematically what is going on
here but well well but the good news is
we're building an archive
in other words these companies never
imagined that anyone would actually
capture and preserve and archive
ephemeral content that's what we're
doing as a as of well I mean the numbers
keeps growing every every minute every
second but literally as of when I
checked uh this morning we had to
preserved more than 41 million of these
ephemeral experiences and we're gonna
preserve hundreds of millions and
eventually billions and we're getting
better and better and better at doing
the analyzes
and I'm just telling you this is what
we're doing is crazy insane complicated
uh in the beginning it seemed almost
impossible but we're doing it and this
to me is the real protection that we can
have from not just Google but the next
Google after this one because
if you don't Monitor and capture
preserve archive ephemeral content
you'll never understand what's going on
you'll never understand why this person
won the election versus that person
you'll never understand what's happening
to kids
I mean human autonomy literally will be
undermined and people won't know
you have to monitor in other words this
is not optional for Humanity okay maybe
my monitoring system is optional because
I could get you know run over by a
Google Street View vehicle tomorrow
please I'm sorry let's go a different
direction different direction completely
so incognito mode does that do anything
for us is that just a are they just
messing with us with Incognito that's
completely fake completely fake I knew
it
I wrote this question down earlier
because you said with Google like
obviously all of these things exist and
I'm thinking okay well what service do
you use and then I was thinking well
wait a minute does incognito mode
actually do anything so what what do you
use
if you go to
myprivacytips.com you have this whole
list I do okay that's why I finally
started using these these cool domain
names because I couldn't remember the
links so
myprivacytips.com will take take you and
your four members of your audience too
come on it's five is it five let's do
five as you said four or five damn
that's a 25 increase it is wow we'll get
Google on getting more here okay so my
privacytips.com will take you to a piece
which begins this article I wrote and it
begins I have not received a targeted ad
on my mobile phone or computer since
2014.
nice so it'll explain to you how you can
get started in preserving your privacy
and I first published that in 2017 and
good news for your viewers is that I
just updated it a few days ago so now
it's okay all everything's up to date
and and it'll get you started okay uh
one of the things I mentioned I'm just
gonna flash this and put it put it down
is that I every single person here has a
surveillance phone in their pocket in
their purse somewhere those are all
surveillance devices yes they really do
listen to every single I don't doubt it
and remember a few years ago
I don't know you look a lot younger than
I am but a few years ago it wasn't that
long ago you could remove a battery from
your phone now they solder them in so
you can't remove the battery why would
they do that convenience I'm just
kidding of course I know yes it's so you
can never turn off your phone not
completely you think it's off and it's
not off those are surveillance devices
they they're they're listening they're
recording uh if you disconnect from your
mobile service provider then yeah
they're just storing everything locally
on the phone but the moment you
reconnect all of it gets uploaded
uh we don't do that we we actually build
our own phones for our key staff members
and these are secure phones this is what
people and who work for you know the NSA
or the CIA this is what they use and uh
if you want to you know if again if you
go to my privacytips.com I'll I'll
explain to you if you want to start
experimenting with secure phones how you
can do that okay now it's very practical
good advice too yeah right I don't think
a lot of people know this or really
maybe it's the want to know this like
ignorance is bliss it's not in this case
because you just you know end up in a
very dark place as a society but I think
we're pulling back the blinders for a
lot of people I mean people have come on
and said ah you shouldn't have a phone
and like ah whatever you just don't like
apple or you're an Android guy whatever
it may be but you're you're basically
saying like look it's
if you're serious about this these are
the things that you can do to take steps
you can support this kind of
surveillance system right you can you
can sponsor the 25 a month uh at a
minimum I know we can get stuff like
that done right but there's also things
you can do with your phones you can stop
being the product right because that's
what Google counts on is you you're the
product right your information all of
that data that is the product
so we don't use and I say we my my
friends my family my staff none of us
use anything that has anything to do
with Google so uh none of us use the
Google search engine none of you
listening or watching should ever use it
again because it's an extremely
aggressive uh surveillance tool but it's
also the most powerful mind control
machine ever invented in history there's
so many different ways in which that
search engine is manipulating you that
again if you really understood trust me
you would never touch it again so what
do you use we use Brave brave.com uh
that's our that's we use for our browser
Brave has its own search engine it's
built into it it's the brave search
engine uh it works extremely well yeah
um we for texting and that kind of stuff
we use signal it's a free app it's run
by a non-profit organization a signal is
uh excellent It's true that there are
some of the big tech companies have
tried to diss it and try to make up
stories I wonder why but even Edward
Edward Snowden the the guy who who
brought all that creepy data you know
out of the intelligence agencies a few
years ago uh even he uses signal so yeah
we use signal you can use signal for
video calls for regular calls it
encrypts everything for email for please
stop using Gmail please please please I
beg you
you should be using uh protonmail and
that's based in Switzerland uh it's
subject to very strict Swiss privacy
laws there's a free version which will
probably get you at least for your first
year but even if you at some point need
the paid version of protonmail it's like
six bucks a month I mean yeah all of
these quote unquote free services
they're not free you pay for them with
your freedom now that's not free to me
if you're paying yeah when you put it
like that with your freedom that's one
of the best articles I ever wrote I
should buy that URL but I wrote an
article called free isn't freedom but I
I need to get that that domain name I I
should do that but
you pay with your freedom you know what
don't do that don't use Gmail get
protonmail it encrypts the messages end
to end and the attachments so that even
the folks at protonmail
can't read it now that's a very
different model very very different
model so instead they're just they're
you know people who really use it
heavily or people are in business so
they're charging a few bucks a month
that's what we should be doing in other
words this company should not be allowed
to use surveillance in a way that's that
we're not you know that we're not aware
of uh to to not not just sell us stuff
but also just to manipulate us yeah the
surveillance business model should be
illegal right well and and you know a
lot of companies now are switching away
from or at least trying to decouple
themselves from the advertisers being
the only way they get paid because then
the advertisers are in control of the
content that gets put on your platform
and they can turn that off at the drop
of a hat depending on how they feel
about you that day
um so when we look at 2024 when we look
at the upcoming elections obviously
we've talked about the primaries we know
that you guys are are there where you're
monitoring this stuff and you're hoping
that your mere presence is enough to get
Google to stand down and not do anything
with these elections
this seems like a national security
issue because it is there there is no
question that this is about National
Security when you're talking about our
elections if we don't have free and fair
elections really what do we have and how
long do we have until this country
descends into a thing that you're not
going to want to be a part of right
you're not going to want to be here for
that because it won't be freedom and
there won't be any semblance of the
America that you grew up with and I'm
not talking about cultural issues I'm
talking about just not having any choice
and who represents you that's the most
basic thing that we have here
why is the government in even in small
parts or or organizations that are
government adjacent or somebody stepping
up and saying you know what that's
that's right we do need to fund
something like that so that we can do it
now I don't want the government do it I
don't trust them I do it either I I
understand I want and if it's the
government I want it to be a state
government or a local government funding
it because you're doing it on a
state-by-state basis anyway and so
states can say you know what hey we'll
take care of everybody in the state of
Texas we'll take care of everybody in
the state of Georgia we'll take
everybody in the state of Michigan why
are these groups not stepping up
especially right now your strongest
argument is to conservatives because
they're the group that feels like
they're targeted the most by this kind
of stuff your data seems to suggest that
too obviously right why are they not
stepping up and saying we got to get
this thing funded because at least it
will give us a fair chance with our
ideas and if our ideas are good enough
people will vote for us if they're not
good enough they won't
fear of Google
a lot of people who who have access to a
lot of money okay they they depend on
Google
for their livelihood they can't take a
chance of Google demonetizing them
demoting them removing them deleting
them they can't take a chance one of the
best articles ever written about this
problem was written by the head of the
biggest publishing conglomerate in
Europe and his P his piece was actually
called fear of Google and he called it
an open letter to the CEO of Google and
he was talking about the fact that they
can't you know they can't do anything in
their business without deciding you know
how Google's going to react because
Google can easily just
snap their fingers with or without cause
and the courts by the way have said yes
you can do this you're a private company
and they can just demote you or delete
you and if you're a publishing house or
any other company you're dead
and the courts in the United States over
and over again said Google yes you can
do that Google because either under CDA
230 which you mentioned or under the
First Amendment so they still have the
First Amendment don't forget
speech apparently but the point is that
there are some very very wealthy
conservatives who I have spoken to about
this problem uh one uh quite recently
and you know I can't really I can't
really give you details but he owns a
chain of something or others around the
country and he's very very wealthy he
can't gamble he cannot take a take a
chance he's in retailing he cannot take
a chance on offending Google
um there's a guy who in the past has
supported us
but he owns a chain of blankety blanks
and he finally or he or his his lawyers
or some of his accountants finally
explained to him or is marketing people
you know what you can't do that anymore
you can't be supporting that work
because we can't take a chance on
offending Google
you know the fact that I live my life 24
hours a day offending Google is pretty
nuts that's pretty crazy it absolutely
is let me let me just change what you
said those companies those guys say we
can't take a chance on offending Google
you can't afford not to
you're in a position to make a
difference
I'm sorry but it's time to to grow a
pair and actually put your money where
your mouth is
nobody ever said this was going to be
easy nobody ever said preserving
democracy was not going to be painful
nobody ever told you that being in a
position of influence and power being
blessed by God with resources I'm not
saying hard work doesn't play a part I
know it does
but you're given that as a steward
there are things worth fighting for
there are things worth putting yourself
at risk for there are things worth
investing in and saying you know what if
everybody feels like I do right now and
doesn't do anything then this is only
going to get worse and eventually you
won't be able to speak up against it
eventually you won't be able to make a
change
you have to be willing to put something
on the line and I agree there are people
out there that have more to put on the
line you're putting your life on the
line every single day
we're putting something on the line
every single day as well and then by
having you on it's like a double whammy
right
but we're talking about the opportunity
for you to stand up and do this I've
talked to some CEOs recently and and one
of them a big company and they deal with
these issues well we can't afford to do
this or be associated with that and like
you can't afford not to
our entire right to do it depends on you
doing it and depends on other people in
your position not being afraid to do
that it will cost you something
but if you don't do it it will cost
everybody else everything
so you have to do it
if here's the caveat
if you actually believe what you say you
believe
if it's just a convenient idea that's
different
but then you need to own that you need
to look in the mirror and say you know
what I don't really believe in this
country and the ideals that started this
that gave me the opportunity to create a
business of what's it called around the
country doesn't matter what it is all of
that I don't really believe in that I'm
just glad it's here that I could take
advantage of that system and make my
money and go sit in my house and make
sure and pray to God that I don't offend
these guys and they don't come for me
next
the only way to make sure that they
don't come for anybody next is for you
to stand up
you have to do it I'm sorry that kind of
pisses me off because people think that
this is going to be easy it never has
been in history nothing great ever has
been and it's going to cost you
something
and you're out there fighting and you
don't even necessarily wear the team
jersey you're not a conservative right
but you're out there fighting this cause
I I there's so many other things that I
really wanted to get to I know we've
already kind of Gone Long here but this
these conversations could go on and on
and on and we've already listed a number
of ways that people can support you
bring that back up really quickly
they can go there if you're we're going
to donate the address Crowder is going
to donate I want you to join us my
Google research.com do it
we talk all the time about joining mug
Club that's another way to fight
but sometimes there are causes we want
to contribute to outside of that this is
one of them
do you want to be able to look at the
election and trust that it was Secure
this is a way to do that guess what if
you can never trust that your elections
are secure again
it's only a matter of time before people
take to the streets it's only a matter
of time eventually you're just going to
think well it doesn't really matter and
you're going to be devoid of Hope
and and we don't want to be in that
place we don't want to be in a place
that's polarized we want to be in a
place where people have diverse ideas
yes but
there's a core set of beliefs that unite
us and then we understand we're going to
have differences
he used to support Hillary Clinton
doesn't anymore it's fine I'm not going
to ask you why
but that doesn't matter we're on the
same team right now we're fighting for
the same cause
there are things like that that unite us
and I know their speeches about being
far more that unites us than divides us
that's absolutely true now there's some
big divides right now we have to bridge
those gaps a little bit
but we have to start here first we have
to be able to trust that the people that
we voted for are the people that end up
in office that is 100 primary
we have to protect the rights that allow
us to do that and we have to step up and
we have to give
and we have to do our part in this I
don't know if it takes exposing more
politicians to what's going on super
Pacs to what's going on groups that say
they fight for justice and for freedom
and for the First Amendment and the
Second Amendment all of these groups
you'll take probably donations from
whoever's willing to step up and give
you them right as long as there's no
strings attached to that money right
so do it do whatever you can do to get
more people to watch this episode to
understand what's going on and then send
them to give
because that's really the only way that
we can stop this it's not just about
elections though that's the major thing
right it's about our kids
it's about every single aspect of Our
Lives being controlled by big
corporations
that are accountable to no one
and get favorable treatment it seems in
the courts where
sorry nothing we can do about that you
just I guess don't exist there if
they're a private company they can do
whatever they want you're the digital
Town Square now
things have changed
if you as people who have resources
don't step up if the elected officials
that we have Don't Step Up
if there aren't future Robert
epsteins that stand up
what are we doing here
this is all theater
if that's the case
it's not making any difference we have
to stand up we have to fight
Dr Epstein thank you very much for doing
that I really appreciate it thank you
for spending some time with us today I
know we went over a little bit on time
I'm a little fired up this is this is
intense stuff that you're doing it's not
he's not selling something he's not
coming to you to try to
line his own Pockets he's trying to
fight to save our country
let's join him in that fight
[Music]
[Applause]